bonsoir à tous nous sommes le vendredi
23 septembre bienvenue pour ce nouveau
numéro du 7-8 hebdo une mission pour
revenir sur l'actualité de la semaine
voici les titres l'agglomération de
saint quentin en yvelines se mobilisent
pour soutenir les jeunes entrepreneurs
et les start up et hier se tenait la
première séance plénière de l'incubateur
au ski tube
une soixantaine de personnes étaient
réunies pour fixer la stratégie de ce
nouvel espace est dédié à l'innovation
durant cette émission michel laugier le
président de saint quentin sera notre
invité nous reviendrons notamment avec
lui sur le conseil d'agglomération qui
s'est tenu en début de semaine et puis
bien sûr dans cette émission le reste de
l'actualité avec les maires en colère
contre la baisse des dotations de l'état
ils se sont réunis mercredi devant
l'assemblée nationale ou encore la
problématique la polémique plutôt qui
enfle autour de la supposée
installations d'un camp migrants à
louveciennes nous on ouvre ce journal
sur ces images celle de l'inauguration
officielle ce matin d'une nouvelle
résidence étudiante à la verrière 180
chambres de 19 mètres carrés situé à
proximité de la gare sncf toutes les
chambres sont d'ores et déjà occupé
l'agglomération compte désormais deux
mille logements étudiants sur l'ensemble
du territoire
une autre nouveauté dans l'actualité
avec
hier la première séance plénière de
l'incubateur ski tube un espace dédié à
l'innovation qui ouvrira ses portes
officiellement dans deux mois pour aider
les jeunes entrepreneurs et start-up
agrandir les précisions et les détails
de michael et demi d'euros un nouvel
espace dédié à l'entrepreneuriat va voir
le jour dans deux mois saint quentin en
yvelines selon sky tube installé près de
la gare la structure va accompagner de
jeunes startups du territoire il va
aider une trentaine de jeunes chefs
d'entreprise
à accélérer leur réussite
professionnelle à à monter leurs
prototypes à acquérir les qualités de
management de savoir
à voir leurs premiers clients de
travailler dans des réseaux d'entreprise
j'aurais adoré avoir un incubateur de ce
type là je pense que tu vas gagner du
temps j'aurais été encore plus efficace
ce mercredi soir dans la salle du
conseil de l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines une soixantaine de
partenaires de la structure se sont
réunis pour rappeler les grandes lignes
stratégiques de l'incubateur se sont
quasiment uniquement des entrepreneurs
de saint-quentin des grosses entreprises
des moyens
seppi également d'autres acteurs
économiques qui vont jouer un rôle dans
cet incubateur dans cet accélérateur de
croissance de nos cous entrepreneurs des
dizaines de candidatures ont déjà été
reçues pour intégrer skype youtube dans
les prochains mois au total une
trentaine de dossiers sont reclus michel
laugier président de l'agglomération est
notre invité pour cette émission bonsoir
bonsoir vous avez vous même présenté cet
incubateur on l'a vu dans ce reportage
vous avez présenté ses objectifs c'était
hier soir cet incubateur ce ski club qui
skie cube qui va qui va ouvrir
officiellement dans deux mois c'est une
nouvelle preuve que la priorité absolue
de l'agglomération aujourd'hui c'est le
développement économique c'est comme ça
qu'il faut le qu'il faut le voir leur
visage et a tout à fait on a dit haut et
fort le développement économique fait
partie de la priorité absolue du
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
nous sommes est de loin le deuxième pôle
économique après la défense aujourd'hui
nous sommes en concurrence avec d'autres
territoires
nous avons une avance sur ces
territoires mais il faut la conserver
voire l'amplifier et donc c'est vrai que
cet incubateur fait partie de la
nouvelle politique menée par
l'agglomération
mais je voudrais aussi dire qu'il n'ya
pas que l'incubateur c'est un nouveau
bâtiment qui sera mis au service du
monde économique
un bâtiment qui sera très visible
puisqu'il
avenue du centre à quelques centaines de
mètres de la gare des gares routières
donc du coeur fort de saint quentin en
yvelines et donc il était important la
maison de l'entreprise aura aussi son
siège à cet endroit là donc ça fait
jusqu'à présent
beaucoup de choses ont été faites mais
je crois que on en faisait trop et
c'était pas assez visibles simplement
regarder la maison de l'entreprise même
avec un gps on ne la trouvez pas donc
aujourd'hui elle sera visible et je
crois que c'est la dynamique qu'il nous
faut pour permettre le parcours
résidentiel
aujourd'hui comment on appelle ce nouvel
établissement justement pour avoir de la
visibilité ses skis tube skittles j'ai
eu juste un petit cube ski cubes alors
on l'a compris c'est pour soutenir les
jeunes entrepreneurs les startups
l'objectif c'est de les faire grandir
sur le territoire et à terme qui restent
qui continue à grandir sur le territoire
c'est une première étape finalement ce
festi cube c'est ce que je vous disais
c'est le parcours résidentiel et le pack
essentiel c'est pour qu'on reste sur
place c'est un petit peu comme dans le
logement savez on commence par du
locatif social et puis après notre but
c'est que les personnes après deviennent
propriétaires ce même territoire
mais là c'est exactement la même chose
c'est permettre à des entrepreneurs de
créer leur boîte même à des étudiants
parce qu'il ya déjà aussi beaucoup de
projets avec le monde universitaire avec
l'enseignement supérieur avec déjà les
entreprises du territoire va hier soir
les chefs d'entreprise qui étaient là
étaient très intéressés par ce que nous
leur avons proposé donc là c'est
permettre la création ensuite avait une
fois que ça a bien démarré
c'est partir vers promo paul là aussi
c'est quand même notre pépinière
d'entreprises et que nous avons sauvé il
y a deux ans sauvée de la faillite
complète donc aujourd'hui elle est à
nouveau très opérationnelle est donc ce
sera celui disait le parc résidentiel et
après notre volonté que ces entreprises
qui auront grandi restent sur le
territoire et trouvent un lieu d'accueil
alors ski tube c'est un nouvel outil
pour vous pour attirer les investisseurs
les entrepreneurs quels sont les autres
leviers dont vous disposez pour attirer
les entreprises les grands groupes et
aussi cessé la fiscalité avait déjà
exemple déjà oui vous savez depuis que
nous sommes en place depuis
deux ans et demi nous n'avons pas voulu
augmenter la fiscalité sur les
entreprises ni sur les ménages dont déjà
c'est un signe la deuxième c'est que
aujourd'hui les agences de notation qui
se penche sur notre budget ont vu que
malgré le désengagement de l'état je
vous rappelle que nous avons perdu 10
millions d'euros en deux ans et que
l'année prochaine devrait le retrouver
aussi 5 millions d'économies s'était
jamais arrivé c'est s'était jamais
arrivé à 50 ans des lignes bien malgré
ce désengagement malgré les restrictions
que nous avons pu faire on fait des
choix courageux qui aujourd'hui sont
retenus par les agences de notation
c'est un signe fort aussi pour les
entreprises et surtout ensuite que les
entreprises puissent rester sur le
territoire
et ça c'est plutôt au niveau de
l'aménagement de notre territoire que
nous avons toutes ces possibilités là un
nissan europe doit arriver bientôt à
saint quentin en yvelines
est-ce qu'il ya d'autres grands groupes
qui se sont manifestés qui vous ont dit
on est intéressé par le territoire
s'installer ici
alors moi je plongeais dans les cartons
tout à fait dans il ya beaucoup de
projets mais moi ce que je regarde c'est
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui c'est à dire
que quand des sociétés sont installés
dans des bâtiments anciens vieillissant
devenu obsolète pour leur activité moi
ce que je vois c'est que ce société
souhaitait rester sur le territoire ça
dge été le cas mais que sodexo avec
malakoff médéric avec egis et je vois
que ça continue nissan europe été
installées mais très dispersé gens dire
sur d'autres territoires et surtout avec
aussi des annexes dans des villes
périphériques ou des villes plus
lointaines dont nissan europe
aujourd'hui a souhaité regrouper toute
son activité en un seul bâtiment les
travaux sont en cours
moi j'en suis très heureux de même que
j'ai rencontré les dirigeants de bmw
france qui eux aussi sont en train de
s'interroger mais finalement ils ont
choisi de rester sur le territoire de
saint quentin en yvelines et moi c'est
ce qui me fait plaisir et je vois
qu'aujourd'hui beaucoup de investisseurs
viennent me voir et souhaite s'installer
installer leurs clients sur le
territoire cinq ans dix doigts c'est
très réconfortant et ce n'est pas le cas
partout
michel auger rester avec nous on passe
maintenant à l'actualité
de la semaine
et l'actualité de cette semaine c'était
notamment la rentrée du conseil
d'agglomération plusieurs points ont
fait débat entre majorité et opposition
c'est normal c'est le jeu démocratique
vous avez notamment été interpellés par
nelly duthu la mère de la verrière à
propos du projet d'aménagement de la
gare bécane alors en quelques mots c'est
un projet important pour la ville et
l'agglomération à projets structurants
1800 logements un pôle d'activité de 80
mille mètres carrés un pôle multimodal
aussi aujourd'hui ce projet est à
l'arrêt et selon la mère de la verrière
vous accusent de ne pas respecter les
choix faits par son équipe municipale
qui ont été élus pour ces raisons elle a
décidé de confier maintenant la maîtrise
d'ouvragé l'état
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que vous
répondez à cela est ce que vous
regrettez ce choix j'imagine que oui
est ce que c'est encore négociable entre
vous alors écoutez mois de juin la
première chose je dirais que la gauche a
été à la tête de cette agglomération
pendant quarante deux ans pendant
quarante deux ans il ne s'est rien passé
à la verrière est là aujourd'hui il
faudrait que la nouvelle majorité en
quelques mois
je rappelle que honey nouvelle majorité
depuis le 1er janvier
en quelques mois on puisse rattraper
tout ce retard
je dis qu'il faut prendre encore un
petit peu de temps pourquoi tout
simplement parce que il ya déçu il ya
déjà 17 heures sujets importants
dossiers importants et qui impacte
quelques communes voisines donc
aujourd'hui il est normal de rassurer
encore travailler mon truc à j'ai bon
espoir que les choses puissent se faire
parce que nous sommes tous responsables
nous avons été élus et donc il a il en
va de notre responsabilité devant les
électeurs et surtout les choix seront
faits simples à bord vous dit rassuré
pourquoi qu'elles sont des inquiétudes
aujourd'hui au sein de la majorité peut
être même peut-être au sein de la de
l'opposition quel était le nom la
remontée des élus non mais tout
simplement aujourd'hui quand vous avez
un projet aussi important avec nombre de
logements très important sur 100
logements pour une ville de 6000
habitants
voilà donc c'est pour ça que ça fait
quand même homme qui peut réfléchir sur
l'attaqué et vars aux communes moi je
n'ai pas trop de souci parce que je sais
très bien que il y aura pas 1600 le joug
embauche préfère 1600 1800 il y aura pas
1600 logements comme ça du jour au
lendemain tout ça va mettre plus de
vingt ans pour se mettre en place
donc moi j'ai plutôt confiance par
contre est la mère de la verrière le
sait bien la menace de confier à l'état
ça veut dire qu'on ne contrôle plus rien
et là ça va prendre du temps encore plus
ça va prendre plus de temps et y aura
beaucoup plus de logements sans aucune
maîtrise dont je crois que ona un
intérêt commun et l'agglomération et la
ville de la verrière a continué nos au
dialogue a continué nos négociations
pour aboutir un projet concret alors
autre point qui a fait débat c'est la
subvention c'est le vote de subventions
pour des associations et notamment des
associations culturelles
globalement depuis que vous êtes arrivé
à la tête de l'agglomération
l'opposition vous reproche de baisser le
moyen pour la culture attrape par
exemple la dotation pour les équipements
culturels merise et grenier à sel est
passé en deux ans de plus de cinq cent
mille euros à à peu près 80 mille euros
la ville s'est produit récemment la
communité sur le sujet on parlait tout à
l'heure des priorités l'innovation le
développement économique
clairement la culture c'est pas la
priorité numéro 1 de l'agglomération
d'aujourd'hui je dirais pas ça je dirais
tout à fait le contraire
aujourd'hui je crois qu'il ya des
priorités aussi dans la culture et la
culture c'est qui est prioritaire pour
saint quentin en yvelines
ce sont les équipements et la politique
intercommunale est pas la politique
communale donc aujourd'hui le théâtre
ces cas même l'agglomération qui
subventionnent à des auteurs très
importante
elles mangeaient leurs et orientations y
est nommé il ya de réorientation des
onze qui intercommunale c'est normal que
nous l'assumerons à fond et même plus
vous rappelle quand même que nous sommes
en train de terminer les travaux de la
médiathèque du cada nous allons y
intégrer
musée à l'intérieur donc on fait quand
même pour près de 7 millions d'euros de
travaux
alors quand on dit que des contre la
culture que l'on touche à la culture
excusez moi mais les chiffres parlent
d'eux mêmes donc nous aujourd'hui nous
avons décidé que tout ce qui était
communautaire c'est à 50 années idée
tout ce qui est communal c'est aux
villes assumer c'est trop facile de dire
nous on fait beaucoup en culture quand
ce sont les autres qui paient donc en
plus aujourd'hui ce qui a été décidé par
l'ensemble des maires ces deux cas même
laissé un fonds de concours donc un
fonds de concours de 750000 euros à
répartir mais non plus sur cette commune
mais sur 12 communes puisque aujourd'hui
notre territoire
c'était largy les critères ont été
déterminés et ont été fixées par
l'ensemble des représentants des
communes
et aujourd'hui après vous avez les
projections financières alors certains
sont satisfaits d'autres pas mais ça
c'est le jeu aussi de la politique
intercommunale
un mot enfin sur les jeux olympiques
2024 un sujet que vous avez évoqué lors
du conseil en votant pour approuver des
lettres de garantie alors concrètement
vous assurer que les équipements
sportifs dont dispose st quentin se
serviront pour les jo de paris
si la ville est évidemment désigné hôte
des jo-2020 4 l'agglomération est
toujours à fond derrière ces jo malgré
les critiques parfois qu'on peut
attendre sur le coût exorbitant que ça
peut ça peut avoir de telles de tels
équipements de tels jeux olympiques par
exemple rome a décidé cette semaine de
se retirer de la course aux jo 2000 24
l'agglomération elle reste investi dans
ce projet à à 100%
l'agglomération de saint quentin reste à
son pour saab à 120% investis dans ce
projet aux côtés de la ville de paris de
l'état de la région et du département
des yvelines
c'est inespéré les jeux olympiques ça se
présente une fois tous les cent ans
comment laisser passer de telles
occasions de valoriser notre territoire
et puis en plus je dire nous nous sommes
prêts à saint quentin
il n'y a pas de nouveaux investissements
à 3-1 et en plus il y aura il y aura 10
dura trois sites dans le golfe est prêt
et en plus nous allons prouver dans deux
ans grâce à l'organisation de la ryder
cup qui est la plus grande compétition
de
l'oeuf au monde nos capacités organiser
de tels événements nous avons prouvé
avec les championnats d'europe de
cyclisme sur piste de deux champions du
monde dans un premier temps et
championne d'europe donc quelques jours
dans quelques jours maintenant que nous
sommes en capacité de pouvoir accueillir
les plus grandes manifestations restent
après le dernier site c'est le site de
la colite d'elancourt et là c'est un
site qui appartient à la communauté
d'agglomération et ça fait des années
que dans notre programmation
pluriannuelle des investissements
il y à l'aménagement de cette colline or
la grâce aux jo nous allons déjà à
pouvoir aménager une grande partie de la
colline et tout ça va nous coûter que
25% du coût dont giro même
financièrement c'est une excellente
affaire
vingt-cinq consent ça représente quoi
concrètement un million déjà un million
de voix là doivent mourir portables
aujourd'hui pour l'agglomération un coût
supportable puisque c'est avec ce slogan
que l'on doit il ya des hébergements que
l'on doit aujourd'hui
bon voilà donc et nous en plus on va
bénéficier à près d'un équipement qui de
qui aura coûté cabm au total 6 millions
et nous dedans nous ne nous sommes en
mettront beaucoup moins donc voila moi
je trouve que c'est plutôt intelligent
de voir les choses comme ça en tout cas
moi je peux dire que tous ceux que je
rencontre
que ce soit les présidents de clubs
sportifs de saint quentin
que ce soit les chefs d'entreprise tout
le monde est très motivé par tous les
grands événements que nous avons
organisé regarder la ryder cup le golf
ne s'est jamais aussi bien porté sur
saint quentin en yvelines depuis
quelques années avec tout ce que nous
faisons pour la promotion de
l'initiation en direction des enfants
même des enfants défavorisés de certains
quartiers mais tout ça marche bien et je
pense que l'engouement jiho qui va nous
emmener jusqu'à 2024 sera extraordinaire
et puis vous savez il ya parfois des
événements qui sont remises en cause
suite à l'attentât de nice le 14 juillet
dernier de nombreux rassemblements et
manifestations publiques ont été
supprimés vide greniers courses
sportives ou encore braderie sont
concernés c'est le cas également dans
les yvelines qu'en est-il précisément à
sky florin parfait fait le point on
regarde pas de foire à la brocante cette
année à guyancourt l'événement devait se
dérouler ce dimanche 18 septembre place
du marché il a été annulé en amont
pour des raisons de sécurité et de
budget même sort pour le vide greniers
de la mjc aux clayes-sous-bois prévu
initialement le dimanche 2 octobre
il n'aura pas lieu en raison des
difficultés à sécuriser l'ensemble du
périmètre de cette brocante à voisins le
bretonneux aucun événement supprimés
mais la décision n'appartient pas
seulement aux communes elles doivent
suivre des directives de la préfecture
on est en train de prendre chaque
événement à venir déjà jusqu'au mois de
décembre pour vérifier lesquels on
maintient et peut-être si on a supprimé
la suppression des pans de la
sécurisation que nous sommes en mesure
d'apporter et la préfecture nous demande
de remplir un dossier à chaque
manifestation avec le plan vigipirate
les mesures de sécurité ont été augmenté
par rapport aux éditions précédentes
la vigilance doit redoubler notamment
sur les grands rassemblements on a
renforcé les mesures de sécurité
jusque là on essaie de tout garder parce
que en accord avec la police on est fait
dans des lieux fermés
pas de quoi s'alarmer dans les faits la
majorité des communes de saint quentin
en yvelines n'a pas été impactée pour
l'instant d'autres communes qui
ressentent leur événement dans des
espaces fermés
voilà mais tout cela ça concerne que 10
20 % des communes
la grande majorité des communes n'ont
pas changé leurs événements des
décisions au cas par cas qui ne devrait
pas trop venir perturber le calendrier
événementiel du territoire aujourd'hui
il n'y a pas d'événements organisés par
l'agglomération qui était adulé et
d'ailleurs nous en train de travailler
avec les services de la préfecture pour
l'organisation des championnats d'europe
de cyclisme sur piste et cette
compétition aura bien lieu à saint
quentin en yvelines soleil territoire de
montigny d'autres manifestations sont à
l'étude notamment les courses de plein
air difficile à sécuriser la 16e édition
de la route des quatre châteaux en
vallée de chevreuse en novembre est
d'ores et déjà annulé pour des raisons
de sécurité bélanger on a vu dans le
reportage c'est finalement la préfecture
qui a le dernier mot sur ses décisions
sterk c'est elle qui décide qui vous dit
clairement cet événement on annule ou
alors vous avez votre mot à dire aussi
votre pouvoir de décision alors vous
savez on est toujours dans la
négociation parce que soit ya l'été
l'application stricte des textes soit il
ya la possibilité de pouvoir mettre des
moyens complémentaires donc là
aujourd'hui c'est ce que nous faisons
avec les services de la préfecture avec
la commissaire de police et dont les
choses se passent plutôt bien mais vous
avez vu que certains de mes collègues
comme moi bah tout ce qu'on a fait déjà
dans un premier temps je vais mois
plusieurs heures tant que maire de
monter ni cette fois plusieurs
manifestations de fêtes de quartier par
exemple nous avons toutes organisées au
sein des écoles voilà parce que c'était
des lieux clos et vous pouvez filtrer
les entrées d'eau dans ces conditions là
on peut tout à fait organiser de même
colonna 50 ans aujourd'hui a les moyens
les effectifs en termes de sécurité pour
assurer justement la sécurité de ces
événements ou alors il ya certains
événements qui vont devoir être annulée
ou en discussion avec la préfecture
alors saint quentin en yvelines n'a pas
de moyens d'avoir volé puisque lés
villes entre le président n'a pas mieux
et voir de police c'est au maire sur et
leur pouvoir de police
en tout cas en ce qui concerne par
exemple les choses
d'europe de cyclisme effectivement par
contre il y aura on va faire appel bien
sûr à des sociétés privées aussi pour
nous encadrer en complément de la police
nationale et de la plaine municipal de
montigny qui vont venir nous aider mais
là aussi nous sommes dans un lieu clos
donc c'est un peu plus facile
j'aimerais pas être à la place du préfet
pour l'organisation du paris versailles
la grogne des mers également dans
l'actualité
jeudi de nombreux élus locaux se sont
réunis devant l'assemblée nationale pour
protester contre la baisse des dotations
décidé depuis plusieurs années par le
gouvernement
reportage d'haussmann vendeurs des stops
à l'asphyxient des départements c'était
le message hier des 400 élus réunis
devant l'assemblée nationale face aux
baisses drastiques des dotations de
l'état
une baisse qui concerne aussi le
département des yvelines à hauteur de
288 millions d'euros
ce sont des sommes absolument
considérable que l'état ne nous donne
plus alors que il décide de nos dépenses
les dépenses sociales et ils ne
compensent pas alors que normalement il
a cette obligation constitutionnelle
pour le seul département des yvelines
sur un budget d'un milliard d'euros
c'est plus de 280 millions d'euros que
département nous toi chaque année donc
vous imaginez bien que nous sommes
obligés de baisser le service ovi noir
et d'augmenter la fiscalité ce qui est
doublement l'insupportable est assez
dure pour les yvelinois ces coupons des
conséquences sur les dépenses sociales
comme le rsa l'apa pour les personnes
âgées ou encore l'éducation
c'est un média important fonctionnement
125 millions d'euros par an on ne peut
pas diminuer il faut bien que les élèves
et ce qu'il faut à la rentrée on prouve
qu'on continue à entretenir nos collèges
qu'on puisse aussi équipé en
informatique voilà donc payer tout est
gai tout un plan à la fois en
investissement fonctionnement donc cette
baisse nous en nous nous a fait prendre
des décisions qui sont qui ont des
lourdes répercussions sur les yvelinois
et c'est pour dire ça suffit
aucun représentant du gouvernement l'a
souhaité réagir sur cette mobilisation
mais les élus ne perdent pas espoir ils
tenteront à nouveau de se faire entendre
lors du congrès des départements à
poitiers du 5 au 7 octobre la baisse des
dotations si un sujet qui concerne
également saint quentin vous en parliez
tout à l'heure - 5 millions d'euros en
2016 ça va être moins 5 millions d'euros
aussi en 2017
tout à fait c'est 15 millions qu'elles
sont moins en moins sur trois ans auquel
il faut pas sûr aussi rajouter parce que
comme le disait pierre b dit dans le
reportage le président du conseil est
exactement vous avez bien sûr les
baisses de dotations mais vous avez
aussi vous savez les péréquations dont
les péréquations vient prendre dans la
solidarité ouais voilà c'est la
solidarité on prend aux uns pour donner
aux autres dont du coup vous êtes
doublement pénalisés et là c'est vrai
que ça peut pas durer mais c'est la même
chose dans chacune de nos communes et
d'ailleurs tous les maires quelques
sensibilités qu'ils soient sont
aujourd'hui très très inquiet parce que
on a de moins en moins de moyens
on a de plus en plus aussi de charges
qui ne tombe sur le dos regarder je vais
prendre un exemple de montigny le
bretonneux
c'est un million de moins chaque année
de dotations de l'état dans le cadre de
la dgf
c'est au salon globale de fonctionnement
voilà deux fois que cette banque
c'est aussi c'est aussi un million cinq
de péréquation dont c'est à dire avec le
fonds de sociétés de la région ile de
france et c'est aussi 900000 euros
imposé par la réforme des rythmes
scolaires
alors comment on fait pour répondre à
toutes ces baisses de moyens et bien
d'autres les impôts mais non moi si je
ne le fais pas parce que je n'ai pas
fait à 50 ans mais je n'ai pas fait à
saint quentin
parce qu'aujourd'hui nous sommes dans
cette politique là dans cette volonté là
mais c'est vrai que finalement quand
vous réduisez aussi les services auprès
de la population
ces visites est aussi pénalisé un petit
peu les habitants mais il vaut mieux le
faire de cette façon là plutôt que de le
faire financièrement
aujourd'hui le gouvernement a beau jeu a
beau jeu de dire on va diminuer les
impôts sur le revenu c'est faux on n'a
pas nui impôt sur le revenu
c'est à dire que ce qu'ils n'ont plus
donné aux collectivités ils vont essayer
de le lan de fade de leur donner un
petit peu aux habitants mais vous savez
personne n'est dupe personne n'est dupe
je crois qu'on doit assumer ses choix
dernier sujet qu'on va évoquer avec vous
la polémique et l'inquiétude cette
semaine autour d'un centre d'accueil
pour migrants qui devrait s'installer
bientôt dans les yvelines
des premières informations qui ont fuité
dans la presse par les dunks alley l'iss
située sur la commune de louveciennes d
information démentie ensuite par la
préfecture après un rendez vous avec
elle la mairie les précisions avec
michael et demi d'euros un camp de
migrants va-t-il être installés ici à
louveciennes la rumeur enfle depuis
plusieurs jours la préfecture des
yvelines a ciblé plusieurs sites sur le
département dont la plaine de villevayre
pour accueillir une centaine de migrants
le lieu en question est un ancien pôle
industriel de 24 hectares actuellement
en friche situé à proximité de ces
discothèques et du triangle de
rocquencourt une nouvelle est une façon
de faire qui agace le maire de la
commune
c'est toujours si vous voulez embêtant
enfin je veux dire
agaçant pour pas dire fortement
irritants d'apprendre les choses par par
là par les médias et que les maires qui
sont quand même le premier niveau de
démocratie démocratie locale n'ait pas
été informé j'ai été irrité par le fait
qu'on puisse nous imposer que l'état
puisse nous imposer
des des choses que nous n'avons sur
lesquels nous n'avons pas été concertés
une nouvelle qui préoccupe également le
front national la section départementale
du parti de marine le pen a organisé
hier un rassemblement devant la mairie
de versailles
nous ce qu'on dénonce c'est de manière
générale l'immigration illégale
et maintenant qu'elle souhaite que cette
immigration illégale ce s'installe dans
les yvelines c'est déplorable
effectivement pour les yvelines et pour
les habitants des en tant que secrétaire
départementale des yvelines c'est de mon
devoir de le dénoncer
selon la préfecture des yvelines aucune
date ni aucun lieu précis n'ont été
retenu à ce jour alors pour le moment 50
ans en tout cas les villes de saint
quentin ne sont pas concernées par
l'accueil des migrants y mord pas cet
été quelle est votre position à vous en
tant que président de l'agglomération et
de maire de montigny sur l'accueil qui
doit être réservé à ces réfugiés ces
migrants on sait qu'à droite il ya
beaucoup de choses qui sont dites de
choses un peu parfois considéré assez
grave sur le sujet et pas forcément à la
hauteur d un politique vous savez moi je
pense que dans une résidence et de la
concertation
on peut rien faire si il y à un dialogue
avec les maires après il faut qu'ils
aient un vrai plan et il faut qu'il y
ait une solidarité qui doit jouer il
faut qu'elle s'applique à tout le monde
mais je pense que dans un premier temps
j'avais notre pays est grand la france
il ya des ya des endroits en france
aujourd'hui les populations sauf en de
plus en plus rare dont je crois qu'il ya
des endroits où on pourrait très bien
logés tout tout tout ces populations qui
peuvent arriver en sachant déjà aussi
c'est qu'il faut savoir c'est pour
combien de temps moi j'ai vu quand même
vu beaucoup de migrants qui ne voulait
pas rester en france donc voilà il faut
qu'on soit précis qu'on soit clair mais
surtout qu'on ne passe pas par dessus
l'autorité municipale que sont les
maires il faut qu'ils aient des
l'information de la concertation et que
le nord n'impose rien sinon les choses
se passeront très mal c'est la fin de ce
set 8 hebdo merci merci de nous avoir
accompagnés pendant cette demi heure je
rappelle que vous êtes le président
divers droite de saint quentin en
yvelines et maire de montigny le
bretonneux également et merci à vous
aussi de nous avoir suivis bon ok mais
aussi à la semaine prochaine